uh this was a few years ago she she
performed I didn't know that she
performed at a Paralympics event uh and
was fantastic but she cut her hair very
short and I uh rather cheekily I admit I
went on Twitter and said I think Rihanna
should grow her hair back fast and she
replied by she came off stage actually
and immediately replied to me you should
grow your bleep fast referring to a a
lower part of my abdominal region
well well let me say this to you I I I I
don't agree with that come back
but I was but I would but I would tell
you this I would tell you this I also
don't agree with your assertion of
Rihanna Rihanna on her worst day looks
better than most women she is a very
very beautiful you know what I actually
don't disagreement on here and I
definitely think that you I actually
think that you are a bit off kilter
there it's pretty hard to find a woman
more beautiful than Rihanna I think you
crossed the line there I think you raise
a very good point